[Musique]
je suis en voiture
je suis un feu il ya quelqu'un qui t'a
pas mon quart ou jeu mais bon la
personne n'a reconnu
c'est ben voilà personne m'a reconnu on
était un feu voilà la personne de me
parler et là je baisse sa vitre la
personne me dit bonjour monsieur ce que
vous pouvez me déposer make money where
jusqu'au point de déposer mais bon j'ai
pas de sou tout ça est ce que vous
pouvez me déposer comme vous êtes
chauffeur voilà six ans sur votre route
direction est longue c'est vrai que
j'avais une voiture qui fait un peu
chauffeur et donc j'ai pris le gars
allez on dans la voiture elle entendit
je vais dit vas-y mon frérot il est prêt
à le gaver 88 ans mais voilà mais je dis
quand même offrir ou et voilà donc il
est venu je l'année mais le pire c'est
que appris il m'a engueulé mais non
lalart kaseja c'est qu'à un moment je
réserve qui joue à sous mais là je vous
avais dit la haye pays bas mon sac le
tour maintenant
ayrault et donc j'ai refait le tour je
les laissais bah oui donne franchement
voilà il m'a dit il est parti même pas
un merci mais rien en vous avez fait ça
que j'ai fait ça gratuitement
je vais vous raconter parce que c'est
vraiment un truc de ouf je suis
tranquillement je suis allé chercher mes
enfants à l'école et j'étais avec mon
ami youssef on arrive et on rentre à la
maison c'est youssef qui conduisait on
avec les enfants derrière et là youssef
comme il est très fine et on ne veut pas
faire un créneau
il rentre comme ça l'amérique est ce à
dire qu'il est un créneau à la fois chez
moi mes frères voilà voilà la tunisienne
donc il va direct et sur moi il y avait
une mini austin était garé là une mini
mes frères il a des fonctionnaires mais
la voiture elle est payé mon frère et
les enfants dérangeaient discret mon
frère les enfants qui crient dans la
boîte c'est là que pour cela je reçois
un sms
frérot tu as voulu tuer ma femme quoi
arthur non c'était la peau par hasard
des fonds c'est sacrément d'une écoute
fait les réparations et on se parlera
dans cinq six sept ans attendait
maintenant je suis allé aux états unis
je suis allé aux états unis je suis à la
new york sachez que j'ai passé 12 heures
à l'aéroport de new york
on n'était qu'un pote jean rachid n'a
mis que vous connaissez on a passé la
douane et donc le mec arrive ils
commencent à nous interroger
bon c'est vrai que l'anglais faut savoir
que je ne parle cent fois mieux anglais
que mon ami déjà le niveau du gars qu'on
arrive
as de coeur qu'il faut les de la iame
jimmy fallon in french jimmy fallon est
l'hôte et google lysozyme on est resté
deux heures avec le gars il dit pourquoi
vous êtes là qu'est ce que vous avez
fait pourquoi vous allez venir pourquoi
tous avons là après il nous laisse
partir là on fait 50 m il ya un autre
gars qui fait là il faut que nos sacs
savez que je suis fan de crimes de
crimes de trucs comme ça à détecter et
j'ai acheté deux revues une revue
d'effectif et notre volonté a marqué en
énorme criminelle çà et là comme ça ils
appellent tout faire et donc idylle
prend mon passeport et son bagout bbc
ouais c'est vrai tu huawei a way est
donc là les gars super sympathique
du coup on a pris un petit verre avec
une chaussure eric après ils m'ont dit
you come back when you je pense que la
marine comme ça
à